These divers are gearing up to head 400 feet
underwater.
Their bodies will experience immense, almost
fatal, pressure that can literally turn the
very thing keeping them alive — against
them.
“The longer you stay down there, the more
gas, mostly helium, also nitrogen, on boards
into your tissues, into your blood, into your
muscles, into your bones; it’s just building
up inside your body and you have to let that
out.”
The Twilight Zone is one of the most mysterious
and dangerous places on Earth.
Only an elite team can handle the complexities
of diving at these depths and conduct scientific
research.
Their job is a race against time to survey
these deepwater coral before they come under
serious threat from pollution and warming
ocean temperatures.
“I would say less than 10, 15 scientists
worldwide go to those depths.
And because of that, everything is new.
Everything is novel.
We don't know what's there, because nobody
goes there.”
Luiz Rocha is one of only a dozen of divers
in the world with enough expertise to reach
the twilight zone.
A place you don’t want to visit alone.
“We're dive buddies, so Luiz and I, we’re
almost inseparable, both on land and underwater.”
Bart and Luiz are equipped with nearly 180
pounds of gear.
Fins, bailout tanks, propeller scooters, and
dive computers — these are all essential
to surviving in the twilight zone.
“Getting all the gear on, on the boat, and
getting ready to drop into the water is definitely
the most intense time.
We make sure our straps are all clipped, we
make sure our valves are on.
It's hot, you're in the sun, in Neoprene,
black, dying basically.”
The key piece of equipment that will keep
Bart and Luiz alive is called the rebreather.
Because at the levels they're going, the normal
mix of oxygen and nitrogen actually becomes
toxic.
“The deeper we go with nitrogen, the more
narcotic it becomes.
So it's the equivalent of diving drunk.”
“We make the sign to descent and we go down
together.
That can be a 300 foot free fall.”
“When you're in a shallow tropical coral
reef it's well lit, it's warm, and as we go
deeper we see the transition.
Everything becomes slower, and colder, and
darker.”
“Then finally you'll start to see the bottom
come up and that's when you work.
You have your 10 minutes, your 15 minutes
on the bottom.”
And that’s it.
That’s all the time that these divers can
spend exploring the Twilight Zone before all
that gas they’re inhaling becomes lethal.
“It requires constantly monitoring yourself
for symptoms of all kinds of different aspects
of different gases interacting with your body.
So we have to be constantly thinking about
our gear and ourselves, and at the same time,
trying to do science at those depths.”
During their incredibly short window of time,
the dive team have to survey their surroundings,
catalogue coral and capture new species.
In fact, they’ve been known to collect 12
new species in just a single dive.
“It's really intense.
All you're thinking about is, "Catch the fish.
Do the job that I'm here to do.
Where's my buddy?
Okay, everybody's okay.
What's the time?
OK I’ve got a little bit more time.”
“We have our own language and screaming
gestures, and taglines, and things like that
that we'll use to communicate and then we'll
scream at each other in our ridiculous helium
voices if we see something really exciting,
you know, come over here and look at this
fish.”
Bart and Luiz would spend hours down in the
Twilight Zone if they could, but it's time
to ascend.
“We have an agreed upon time where we leave,
what we call the TTS, the Time To Surface.”
Ascending too fast can cause life threatening
conditions, like decompression sickness or
the bends.
So Luiz and Bart follow a very specific decompression
schedule, which means ascending in stages.
“If we have 10 to 15 minutes at the bottom,
it could be 3-4 hours after that to come back
up to the surface.”
The longest stop is just before Bart and Luiz
surface - just 10 ft below the waterline where
they can spend up to 90 minutes.
90 minutes in just one spot.
“I’ve had about 300 hours of rebreather
diving now in the past few years doing this
project, and when you think about it, it's
probably like maybe a sixth of that is in
the Twilight Zone and the rest of it's all
the decompression.
But you know, it's worth it.”
Bart and Luiz are just beginning to scratch
the surface of the Twilight Zone.
And the information they collect from these
deep reefs are invaluable.
They’re so rarely studied, that we could
be in danger of losing them before we fully
understand them.
“Every time we go to those depths, We find
plastics, we find fishing gear//We find all
signs of human activity, even as deep as we
go, to 400, 500 feet.”
And Bart and Luiz are willing to go through
the process of donning heavy equipment, risking
decompression sickness and spending hours
underwater, over and over again, just so they
can better understand this world.
“It's definitely worth it to be able to
go down there and see places that no person
has ever seen before.”